- Am I having regrets?
It's a little weird.
The flipping doesn't (gasps)
(beep)
Hi, I'm Alexis.
And if you know anything about
my cooking style, you know
I love using an ingredient
in as many ways as possible
it cuts down on food waste and
it's better for your budget.
So today my friends, Betsy and Katie
have challenged me to
make a three course meal
using only five ingredients.
I don't know what they are,
but I think I'm excited.
I'm ready.
- [Katie] I'm so scared for you.
- [Alexis] Love this! Okay!
Initial thoughts, I'm like,
these are all ingredients
I have at home.
Dessert is gonna be weird.
For my surprise ingredients
I have corn cereal,
chickpeas, shrimp, lemons,
and carrots.
- [Betsy] So I know at
home you've got a pantry.
So we are gonna give you
a access to a few pantry
staples to help you a
little bit along the way.
- [Alexis] And what are
those pantry staples?
Thanks guys.
For my pantry staples I
have flour, olive oil,
sugar, salt, and garlic powder.
I really felt so excited seeing
these surprise ingredients.
And I was like, I can
totally do this in my sleep.
But I really just kind of
blacked out and seemed to forget
that I won't have a full pantry.
I'm gonna brainstorm.
The shrimp shells could be
made into like shrimp stock.
Carrot tops could be like a chimichurri.
With the chickpeas I can make aquafaba.
Wait, do I get any kitchen
tool I want for this?
- [Katie] Absolutely.
Yeah.
- Score!
Whenever I do chef out
of water, I have whatever
ingredients I want, but
a weird cooking tool.
So maybe this will be
easier.
(high tempo drum plays)
(beep)
With whatever I do I wanna
make sure it's like properly
appetizer, main course, dessert.
Okay. I have a plan.
I don't know how I feel about
the plan, but I have one
and we'll see what happens.
I'm so nervous.
I don't know what I'm doing.
- [Katie] Is this harder
than chef out of water?
- This is definitely harder.
So maybe this will be easier.
I'm gonna start with dessert.
I'm just gonna do really simple.
One to one, sugar and water.
Betsy and Katie told me I could use water
very generous of them.
It's making my life a lot easier.
Normally I would blanch the lemons before
but I'm gonna skip that today.
'Cause there's a lot to do.
When you're making a simple syrup
you want the sugar to completely dissolve
and come to a boil, so
it becomes like that
nice syrupy mixture.
My simple syrup's boiling.
I'm just gonna pop the
lemons in and let them go
for five, ten minutes.
I'm gonna move on to my streusel.
I would love some butter right now, but
you know that's part of the challenge.
I also don't really have
one of these in mind,
so I'm really just winging it.
Gonna add some sugar and some salt
nice balance of flavors there.
I'm gonna add a little bit
of the infused simple syrup.
- [Betsy] How you feeling?
How you feeling?
- I don't know.
This is weird.
Maybe I need more sugar.
Let's see.
I mean, this tastes pretty good.
I thought I'd add some olive oil
because I don't have
the fat from the butter.
I don't want it to taste
like olive oil though.
So I think I just need to
be like pretty sparing.
I feel like I'm a kid, like in
the pantry, just like kind of
like grabbing things and
being like, does this work?
I'm hoping that some of this
kind of like clumps together
like a little cereal cluster.
If this works, I will be truly, truly
truly shocked and very
impressed with myself.
My lemons are done though.
I think I'm gonna pop the lemons
on a sheet pan and then
pop them both in the oven
and then move on to the next part.
The last component of my
dessert, is to make a meringue.
Usually to do this, you
would use egg whites
but obviously I don't have any eggs
but I do have chickpeas.
In vegan baking it's really popular to use
aquafaba for meringues,
for, even for savory dishes.
I've never done it before.
We'll see what happens when I try.
(beep)
So to do this I'm just
gonna pour the liquid in.
I just, it's hard to
believe that this works.
Save these for later.
All right.
Just whisk.
(whisk whirs)
So it actually looks
kind of like egg whites.
If I was making meringue, I
would start adding the sugar.
In this case, I'm gonna use
the infused lemon simple syrup
really bringing it home, low waste guys.
And I hope that works.
- [Katie] How you feeling?
- It looks like it's kind of working.
So fine.
Soft peaks.
I'm just gonna give it a little taste.
Um, I'm not sure the simple
syrup is really doing its job.
So I'm gonna do two things and
add regular granulated sugar
and some lemon zest, which I
think are really gonna bring
that the flavors of
meringue whipped cream home.
And we get to use the
lemon in another way.
Win-win.
Let's see if this helps.
(whisk whirs)
Nice. It's a little weird.
Wow. I feel a lot of things.
We'll start with the bad.
The lemons didn't quite
turn out the way I expected.
I'm gonna rectify it by
just chopping them up.
The corn flakes look amazing,
but maybe I should try some.
Hmm.
We're gonna start with crumble
and then I think creamy
and then some lemon.
And I'm just gonna repeat that again.
Double layer.
So cute.
I think this is incredibly charming.
I'm gonna pop them in the fridge.
Move on to the next course.
Now I'm gonna make my appetizer.
I really don't have a plan for this.
To start I'm gonna add some corn flakes.
(blender buzzing)
I have an idea to add the
chickpeas to the corn flakes
and then pulse it all together.
Follow your gut.
But my gut isn't telling me anything.
It looks kind of like chickpea flour
which is actually a really good sign.
That's what I want.
I mean, I don't really know what I want
but I think this is what I want.
Now I'm gonna add some salt.
I think this can be like
pretty generous on the salt
and some garlic powder
because that's the only
other seasoning I have.
Some olive oil and then
I thought I would add
some aquafaba to have it
stick together a little bit.
I want it to be like pancake batter
so I think I'm gonna add some water.
Confidence is just not
very high right now.
I think before I add more water
I'm gonna do a test pancake.
I'm gonna use olive oil.
If I was at home I'd probably use an oil
with a higher smoke point.
I don't have any cooking time
because this isn't a real recipe
and I've never done it before.
So I'm just gonna wait
to see what happens.
The flipping doesn't- (gasps)
I didn't put flour, duh.
I'm gonna add some carrots
and some flour and try again.
I really believe that this is gonna work.
And I think a few tablespoons of flour.
It's really about getting
that right texture
of like making sure it
holds together enough.
And also that it's
loosen enough to spread.
Look at that.
Okay. Cute.
It looks like the side
are kind of firming up
so let's take a look.
(Alexis and Katie gasp)
That looks gorgeous.
This is a fritter.
Confidence level just shock.
Hmm. I'm gonna make a few more of these.
Make them a little smaller,
more uniform and move on.
Whenever I make fritters I love
having like a saucy element
to go along with it.
To get started I just want to
chop some of the carrot tops.
Oh, it smells so good.
It smells like you're
walking into a garden.
It's just like carrot.
You know, even if I had been given pepper
I think that would've been helpful, but...
Lemon juice, this is
also gonna be really nice
to like cut the like fattiness
the richness of the fritter.
And this is just a little salt.
Yeah. That's kinda cute.
I'm just gonna plate this,
which is incredibly easy.
I think it looks like really cute.
Very creative.
You can do so much with so little.
This is really cute.
Appetizer set.
I'm gonna finish up with the main course.
Okay, so for my main dish,
it feels really ambitious
but I'm gonna try to make
pasta in a shrimp brodo.
To start I have to make the shrimp stock.
I'm gonna use these carrot tops
which have like so much flavor in them.
Just add them right to the water.
Whenever I'm making shrimp at home,
we always save the shells
and keep them in a bag in the freezer.
I'm also gonna use this
lemon that I zested before.
There's still a few peels on
here that I think I can get.
I'm gonna add some salt because
I don't have real garlic.
I'm gonna add some of the garlic powder.
Yeah.
Now onto the shrimp.
I know this sounds really weird
but I actually love peeling shrimp.
Making stocks is such a great
way to use up what you have
in your pantry and in your fridge.
My water's starting to
simmer, I've peeled my shrimp.
So time to add the shells in
and this part is really fun
because the shells turn like
bright pink pretty quickly.
You can totally do this with
shrimp without the heads on
but that's just gonna
add even more flavor.
Isn't that cool?
I'm gonna let the simmer
and move on to the pasta.
I've made pasta so many times
but I've never used aquafaba in it.
I'm really excited to
see how it turns out.
Gonna add some salt and then
pour it right in the middle.
And I'm gonna add a
little bit of olive oil
which is gonna keep it like really tender
and add like a great texture.
At this point, I would start
kneading if it was with an egg.
So I think I'll do the same.
when you're making pasta
it always feels wrong.
You're like, how can this become pasta?
It does feel different than
pasta with an egg in it.
This is a lot harder to knead.
I feel like I could chuck it.
(Katie laughs)
And it would like kind
of knock someone out.
I think this is as good as it's gonna get
gonna put some plastic wrap over it.
Let it hang out for 30 minutes, an hour.
Confidence level five.
My dough's been resting and
actually looks a lot better.
Basically, it looks
exactly how I want it to
which is a shock.
And if you're making homemade pasta
you wanna make sure that
whatever dough you're not using
you are keeping sealed.
When you're making past
start on the widest setting.
I like to go through a
few times on each setting.
I feel like confidence
level now is like 6.5.
One more just to like
get it really perfect.
I can't believe it.
It looks beautiful, I'm so impressed.
I'm just gonna add a little bit
of flour and cut it by hand.
Think I'm gonna do
pauper de la type length.
That feels right.
(gasps)
It's so good.
The day has taken a 180.
Perfect. Wow.
I'm gonna let this pasta hang out.
Can kind of like dry out
a little and then move on.
So now I'm gonna cook my shrimp.
I strain this shrimp stock.
I'm gonna poach the shrimp in the stock.
Since the stock is heated up.
Just gonna add the shrimp right in.
Poaching is a really
nice way to cook shrimp.
I mean look how fast it goes.
It's already starting to turn pink.
Just gonna let that
cook for another minute.
It's looking really good.
Shrimp is done.
I'm gonna keep the broth
just off to the side.
My shrimp are ready to go
and now all I have to do
is boil the pasta.
Just gonna add a little
bit more salt to it
and cook the pasta.
When you're making
homemade pasta the joy is
that it cooks really quickly.
Just wanna kind of gently twirl it
just so it doesn't stick together.
Basically when it starts to
float and come to the top
you're done.
Ooh, the texture is a little weird.
I don't love it.
Doesn't really tastes like pasta.
I don't know guys.
It's kind of sticking together.
Let me add a few shrimp,
maybe that'll salvage.
I think for the ingredients I have,
I've done the best I can.
I just wanna add a little of the broth.
This is gonna help, I think.
Maybe a little olive oil, little salt.
And then I thought I would just put some
of the carrot top greens on
just for a little contrast.
There's nothing else I can do.
I'm gonna get the other
two courses and it's time
for Katie and Betsy to taste them.
Fingers crossed
Betsy, Katie.
- Yes.
- I have made you a three course meal
using only five ingredients, as you know.
- We've been watching it
and we've been impressed.
- Exceeded expectations.
It kind of looks like a full meal.
- [Katie] Should we try
the appetizer first?
- [Alexis] Chickpea
cornflake carrot fritters.
- [Katie] Mm. Nice crunch.
- I, wow.
- I really like that,
it's shockingly good.
- I really, really like this
- [Alexis] Main course.
I'm nervous about this one.
- [Katie] I know you were skeptical
but I'm actually excited.
Okay, cheers.
- [Betsy] Cheers.
- Oh my God.
- That's a little, a wee bit salty.
- [Betsy] I think the
shrimp are cooked perfectly.
- And I don't mind the shrimp stock.
- I find that the texture
of the noodles to be hard.
- [Katie] Very excited for dessert.
- [Katie And Betsy] Cheers.
(Alexis laughs)
(delighted moans)
- Oh, this is shockingly good.
It's like foamy. It's crunchy.
The cornflakes really worked out.
- [Katie] Only five ingredients
in a three course meal.
- [Betsy] I'm impressed.
- [Katie] And you made pasta.
- One thing is for sure, I
cannot believe that you did this.
- I feel really proud, but
if you want more recipes
kind of like this, I
have a cookbook coming
out April 19th and it's
all about, this very thing.
Making the most of your ingredients
in ways that are really
inspiring and delicious.
- And we're so proud of you!
- I love that.
- You can pre order in the link below
and if you wanna see me do
a challenge like this again
let us know.
- And now read your cookbook to us.
(all laughing)
(jazz tune plays)